this
[Applause]
is colossus
[Music]
it came to life here in england at
bletchley park in 1943.
[Music]
the machine raced to decrypt german
messages by analyzing
thousands of words of coded text every
second
[Music]
with its mix of vacuum tubes wires and
switches
[Music]
colossus emerged as the first electronic
programmable computer
its arrival gave the allies a huge edge
in world war
ii and save thousands of lives
it also marked the start of the
information age
[Music]
england built ten of the colossus
[Music]
machines
and they became the heart of its booming
computing industry
[Music]
[Applause]
actually no
this is a replica of colossus the real
machines were destroyed after the war
so that the pesky russians wouldn't find
out about the technology
the metaphor then is a simple one
england dismantled decades of pioneering
computing work
because it seemed like the proper thing
to do
and it suffered the consequences ever
since
i doubt many of you can name a single
tech product
or startup that hails from this country
[Music]
[Applause]
what you'll see next then may come as a
real shock
because in its very subdued
self-effacing way
england has in fact given rise to a
handful of tech companies
that have impacted the world on an
immense scale
i'm heading from london to cambridge and
into the english countryside
to find the best technology that england
has to offer
along the way there will be fancy hair
dryers
and ai infused software hello my name is
your name
and of course there will be a spot of
tea
all on this episode of hello world
[Applause]
silicon valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world
but it's being challenged like never
before crazy tech geniuses have popped
up
all over the planet making things that
will blow your mind
my name is ashley vance i'm an author
and journalist
and i'm on a quest to find the most
innovative tech creations
and meet the beautiful freaks behind
them hello world
if you tried to design the perfect
university town
you would probably fail to think up
something as idyllic as cambridge
it's a city filled with temples to
learning and young
privileged brainiacs hop on a bike
and you can go on a ride through
academic history
from newton's apple tree right on up to
the pub
where watson and crick drank to
celebrate the discovery
of dna's double helix
if that seems boring you can also be
ritually abused at the old cambridge
market
thanks oh it's like sour soap
today cambridge also serves as the heart
of england's tech industry
with its research centers startups and
massive biotech firms
outside of the university the biggest
reason for cambridge's technology
success
is a company called arm it designs
chips and they're the brains at the
center of almost
every iphone and android smartphone
in short the modern world runs unarmed
i've met up with my old friend and armed
co-founder
mike muller to share a warm british beer
and find out how this happened we're in
a pub
what has a pub meant to arm over its
history
we met our first ceo in a pub we are in
the pub that's
about 100 yards away from where we
actually
started and in those days we used to
come here every lunch time so
yeah it's played an important part in
the business right
[Laughter]
farm started on something of a whim
its first major customer was apple which
needed a chip for its upcoming newton
handheld device instead of making a
screaming fast
super hot chip like everyone else arm
decided to make a low power
energy efficient chip soon enough
making low power chips became arm's
thing
it took a while for the bet to pay off
but once mobile phones
and then smartphones arrived arm ended
up as a major force
a lifetime our partners have shipped
over 80 billion different chips
and last year there was about two per
person on the planet so there's about 15
billion
arm chips shipped so they're in
everything phones
printers anti-lock brakes televisions
wi-fi routers cloud servers medical
devices
i could keep going to mueller's point
one of the most innovative and glorious
things built around an arm chip
is raspberry pi
it might not look like much but this 35
assembly of electronics is a fully
functioning computer
there's the arm chip right here tons of
usb ports
an ethernet port even an hdmi port
with this teeny little thing you can do
just about anything
released in 2012 the pie has inspired
near religious devotion
among geeky hobbyists and inventors
some of them show off their pie
creations at things called raspberry
jams
i went to see david pride who has a
shrine to the low-cost
personal computer at his home in
gloucester
what has this little device meant to you
it's changed my life
i was very happy very stable i had a
nice well-paid job but i was very very
bored
and i realized that point if i wanted to
do something
different this was this was the
opportunity to learn the skills that i'd
always wanted to learn electronics
robotics coding
[Music]
his house is littered with pie creations
from motorized cars
to robots greetings to everyone watching
hello world
that's a nice touch his most famous
invention though
is the forbot an ai infused machine
that plays a mean albeit slow
game of connect four that is cool
how long did it take you to make this
about three months of
evenings and weekends so it makes it
oh now i have to go you make your move
but it is now thinking about the move
it's taken
oh you bastard you've just lost i
feel ashamed i feel like i should have
done more for the humans
[Music]
to really understand the soul of the
raspberry pie
i had to head back to its birthplace in
cambridge
and take a boat trip with eben upton
he's the computer scientist
that invented the pie
[Music]
around 2007 eben grew alarmed by the
declining number of computer science
students in england
and decided to try and inspire the
youngsters with a new approach
i've always assumed cambridge is the
best place in the world to study
computer science it's certainly the best
place in the uk
and we saw this collapse in the number
of people applying to study computer
science at the university of cambridge
which is crazy as the computing industry
is blowing up
yeah the community is playing obviously
it's a beautiful it's a beautiful
environment to come and to come and
study in
the theory we came up with was that um
most of us who were arriving in the mid
90s like i did
i had grown up with cheap programmable
8-bit micro-computers
you grew up using the bbc microphone
that's what got you in yeah that's it i
had a bbc micro at school
and sat in the corner of the classroom
and those were beautiful machines
[Music]
supported by the uk government the bbc
micro gave many students
their first taste of coding and the
possibility of what computers could do
i'm just gonna scroll down the pie has
very much followed in this tradition
[Music]
and emerged as a consumer hit along the
way
it's now the third best-selling computer
of all time
behind the mac and the pc
our lifetime dream volume was 10 000
units now we're closing out on 10
million
but as that's happened we've just got
more ambitious we just got more greedy
i guess about what we're trying to
accomplish we've gone from can we move
the needle
from 200 to 600 people applying to
computer science
at cambridge to yeah can we do the same
for other universities can we do the
same for other countries
can we do the same for other subjects
think big jason statham impersonator
think
big
the intellectual underpinnings of
computing began
here in cambridge
in 1833 the cambridge trained
mathematician charles babbage built a
prototype of this thing
the difference engine
it could solve equations with the turn
of a crank and some gears
and is considered the first mechanical
computer
a hundred years later in the 1930s
another cambridge mathematician named
alan turing
devised the concepts behind the modern
day computer
he proved that a machine can be
programmed to calculate
just about anything
[Music]
decades after touring and babbage
cambridge is still at the cutting edge
of computing
companies like microsoft place their
research centers here
to tap into the local academic talent
and to explore their most ambitious
ideas
chris bishop runs this lab and oversees
research in a number of
areas one of the most compelling
and frightening areas is artificial
[Music]
intelligence
this is just an amazingly exciting time
in artificial intelligence
[Music]
more and more tasks are becoming solved
in image understanding
in speech recognition and so on so
although we've got a very long way to go
before we get to the the full
capabilities of the human brain
there is a sense that for some kinds of
tasks sort of the barriers have been
removed
computer scientists have dreamed of
creating a true artificial intelligence
for decades
they've been hunting for a machine that
can equal or surpass
humans recently people like bishop have
started to make real headway
thanks to an approach called machine
learning
if you go back to the time of turing
computing is about logic it's about
determinism
the the code the instructions which the
computer runs are created by a human
what we're seeing in machine learning is
something very different instead of
programming the computer to solve the
task
we program the computer to learn from
experience and then we train the
computer
by showing lots of examples giving it
lots of data
[Applause]
ai powers a ton of experiments here
including this computer vision
simulation
microsoft's connect sensor used to
struggle to make out a hand
and now it can pinpoint the movement of
fingers
there's also an ai powered movie
recommendation algorithm
for xbox that does a pretty good job at
figuring out my eclectic taste in movies
you know actually i mean i did like
twister okay
let's see what happens this time so now
we see a big change
this lab isn't just about entertainment
though they're actually saving lives
with a program that can tell the
difference
between cancerous brain tissue and
healthy tissue
in an mri what you see here is a pretty
nasty
brain tumor so what the machine learning
is doing now is it's labeling it
according to
uh whether it's tissue that's already
died or whether it's tissue that is
cancerous and proliferating this is
really important because this is used to
design
treatment so we'll fire in radiation
from lots of different directions and
we'll tune up the amounts and direction
of the radiation
to try and kill as much of the cancer as
possible but to do as little damage to
the normal tissue
as we can
[Music]
down the street from microsoft there's a
startup that already has its ai
technology in the wild
it's called audioanalytic and you can
think of it as a type of shazam
for real-world sounds we use artificial
intelligence to
allow smart home devices to recognize a
whole range of different sounds that
happen inside your houses
it can make your house a bit secure by
detecting glass windows being broken and
then
turning the lights and scale away in the
burger actually taking active protection
of the things you care about
so what do we have here what is all this
um so we've got a
couple of devices that make the sounds
that this detects
smoke along yeah
it's detected smoke alarm on there
nobody's at home so it's now sending a
imessage another sound um this is
glass break yeah set that off
you can see it says window broken yeah
what is the science behind all of this
we had to do
a whole bunch of innovation in terms of
understanding sounds how to detect them
how to have a machine understand them
even if we take a simple sound like a
smoke alarm
because beep well now we've got two of
them going beep at different times
with a whole bunch of background noise
going on
that's a big ai problem to solve
computers have to be trained to
distinguish one sound from another
and to learn the unique signature of say
glass breaking
of course no two breaking windows sound
exactly alike
so these guys get to relieve stress by
breaking
a lot of glass how many windows
have you had to break windows we've
literally built warehouses for it
on month on end different sizes
different thicknesses different type of
glass
[Music]
how many smoke alarms smoke alarms we've
literally bought all smoke alarms you
can find
on the marketplace and then index to all
of those
that was a huge undertaking logistically
the software can also recognize the
sound of a baby crying
hi daisy hi
and as luck would have it we found a
cute hungry baby on which to experiment
so you can see on the screen it's
detecting the baby crying
audio analytics software already ships
inside a number of smart home products
and the company plans on adding many
more sounds
there we go but for now it's the perfect
technology to discover
when an angry baby has thrown a smoke
alarm through a window
[Music]
i arrived in england at the height of
brexit mania
[Music]
the tourists were happy because the
entire country had gone on sale
some of the locals were morose and some
of them just didn't care
like the people drinking these 20
cocktails
at a fancy hotel bar nothing says hello
to financial ruin like sipping rum from
an elephant
made of legos or gin from whatever this
is
you know who else doesn't care about
brexit
people willing to pay four hundred
dollars for a hair dryer
[Music]
dyson as we all know has perfected suck
now it's on to blow
meet the supersonic
according to the ample dyson propaganda
this is the smartest hairdryer ever
built
it uses an electric digital motor to
produce an intense stream of air
and then sensors to make sure that air
never gets too hot
as a result your hair comes out shinier
and healthier than ever before
i feel like uh i'm two inches taller now
to see how dyson built this thing
i had to leave london and head to the
company's headquarters
in the picturesque town of malmsbury
james dyson founded this company in 1991
and has created his very own engineering
paradise
the dyson campus is littered with his
toys of course you have a plane in the
cafeteria
and made up of a handful of invention
factories
my first stop is with someone who leads
a constant battle
to come up with ideas for brand new
products
and reinvent some old ones
hair dryers just haven't changed in sort
of 60 years if we look at this
this cutaway here um you see they've got
a very large motor inside
like that but that weight you're holding
you know for 20 minutes half an hour
while you're drying your hair
and very very noisy so we thought it was
a really good product for us to get into
dyson spent four years and 71 million
dollars to bring the supersonic to life
and as you might expect they're
obsessive compulsive
when it comes to hair we felt that we
had to learn everything about hair the
science of hair
we had to build our own laboratory to
learn about hair for ourselves and learn
what causes damage what causes shine
what makes your hair look lovely
[Music]
hi matthew hi welcome to lab61 matthew
child is dyson's electric
motor wizard he's spent more than a
decade
developing the core of so many dyson
products
the vacuums have big motors and the hair
dryer has this tiny thing
a miniature turbine this is more
returned to a jet engine you find on a
commercial airliner than anything else
[Music]
[Applause]
how fast does it spill around 115
000 rpm so that's about 1800 revolutions
every
second yeah that seems almost impossible
it's possible through very fast
electronics
and a mechanical system that is able to
take the stresses the strains
for hundreds of hours at full speed
[Music]
the electric motor technology will be
key to dyson's continued push into new
product areas some people say it's
secretly working on an
electric car what types of things would
this be useful in
um well at the moment we've applied it
to the air dryer i'll have to wait and
see what comes next
i knew you would say that i can only say
that
the drive to invent and salesmanship
president dyson
is something of an anomaly here
england's beloved cynicism runs counter
to the hype
field optimism that dominates the tech
industry
the brits do a fine job at promoting a
pub lunch
but do less well at spurring on
entrepreneurs and inventors it's clear
enough though
that when the english really gets stuck
into something they do it well
it's not hyperbole to say that arms
chips have changed the world
or that raspberry pi may well have
altered a generation for the better
and if you're inclined to try and think
big
there remains no better place to do it
than in cambridge
where you can meditate in peace among
the cows
up next on hello world i head to japan
and wake from a fever dream to find this
this and whatever this is